Ali Nelson cared for her family with a
good job working as an optician in
Washington DC that is until her employer
laid her off until you know it's just
thought to be too much and our boss
pretty much said you know we're gonna
have to shut down until further notice
and so that's kind of where we're at
right now so not a small company were so
we're not getting paid
Nelson is part of the nearly 3.3 million
Americans who filed for unemployment
claims in late March government
economists think the kovat 19 pandemic
could put as many as a third of
Americans out of work those most at risk
the 67 million who work in the service
sector the so-called gig economy and the
entertainment industry tom antonella's
had been living the dream in los angeles
voice-over work dancing acting but with
social distancing nell the norm it's
almost impossible for antonella's to
teach or perform so it's pretty scary
somehow shameful which is odd
depressing and did I say scary so
depression scare of fright and and shame
are what I'm cycling through and I can't
explain the shame to you Michael Hicks
of Ball State University in Indiana says
the pandemic will for some workers to
find new careers so I think there's
gonna be a lot of reprogramming by
individuals from those occupations to
deal with people that maybe aren't high
skilled into or high skilled medical or
other fields changing careers for Ali
Nelson who's already in health care may
not happen but she says people have a
new understanding of what it means to
survive this is a proof that people are
living paycheck to paycheck and now
something like this happens and people
aren't prepared for it you can't be
hoping the crisis does lead to a more
systemic economic change in society
rosalind jordan al jazeera washington
all right let's say i get more on the
oil prices now we can speak to our
economics editor a Batali who joins us
from london and i would give us more
detail if you would
well Nick you know we had the
extrordinary situation just last week
where oil prices in some parts of the US
were at seven dollars a barrel and in
one instance the producers have to
actually pay the that take away the oil
so this got to the crucial point where
production in the US would start to shut
down and so this for so we saw President
Trump he had to step in in he routine
and now we realize that he's actually
spoken to NBS and himself as Mohammed
bin Salman II in Saudi Arabia but the
talks had actually started some weeks
ago on March 23rd when when the price he
started to tumble and so now we see that
there's gonna be this emergency meeting
and there could be a production that
President Trump has tweeted that there
could be up to 15 million barrels of oil
which are cut now this is really
interesting because will the United
States actually join this production cut
because they will require more than OPEC
to actually bring this or to bring this
Pro oil price back up to a higher level
where everybody can make a comfortable
living so this is a wait and see
situation where we've got to see when
the United States will actually join the
production cuts itself which would be a
first right and what is the thinking
behind this what will be the impact of
this well you know Nick we've just been
talking about those job numbers we saw
those extraordinary numbers where we got
six million Americans looking for work
we got a demand for demand that's just
falling off a cliff we got you know
Airlines which at which have parked up
their jets and transportation which has
just come to come come to a complete
stop imports exports have had virtually
which the Grand Tour halts as well and
so there's something has to be done to
get the economy going now in order in
normal circumstance it's lower oil
prices will be really appreciative but
once you get low prices which Tom which
are capability of businesses to actually
pump oil on
going then something actually needs to
be needs to be done and this figures out
they would say that you know they could
be jobless it's on more than 25 million
all around the world so this is the
reason why the US president has started
these negotiations with President Putin
and with MBS to succeed where they could
we can get to a point where they start
to introduce some production cuts or I
would leave it there for a moment thanks
very much of a tally on the increase in
the oil price there well millions of
people stand to lose their jobs as the
pandemic hits economies worldwide
factories and businesses have been
forced to shut down with more than 2
billion people in lockdown around the
world the International Labor
Organization says at least 25 million
people could join unemployment queues
globally unions fear India's lockdown of
1.3 billion people will cost tens of
millions of jobs the Economic Policy
Institute says 14 million people in the
United States could become unemployed
Goldman Sachs predicts the US economy
will shrink by as much as 34-percent the
tourism and travel industries have been
hardest hit and British Airways is in
talks to suspend 34,000 workers let's
take this on we can speak to Baron Rafi
is a CEO of harbor a global recruitment
and candidate selection platform adjoins
us on skype from absolute Amsterdam mr.
Arif welcome to the program first of all
let's kick off with these oil price
increases what do you make of what's
happened yeah I think in general it's
good news I think the world is facing
the biggest yeah devastating
virus outbreak almost in history and we
cannot have other problems as well that
we could solve like all precious or
anything we can do to stabilize that
market would help definitely could you
just explain for us why it makes
difference why increasing the oil prices
will help this situation I think it's
about stabilization I think if you look
at all prices recently it's it's going
up and down basically and I think if we
have a stable level now it's more
predictable and if the world becomes
more predictable then businesses can
look ahead further and that will
definitely
I'm making plans to employ people again
right because job loss is around the
globe is scale in speed in which they've
happened I have absolutely no precedent
and the economic shock particularly the
United States they say it could rival
the Great Depression what will then
actually mean yeah I think it will we
can say by now
if you look at the numbers and also the
predictions that you just mentioned of
ILO 25 million worldwide 14 million in
the US I mean we're over 10 already sort
of the 14 we've all hit definitely and I
think the biggest of course now we are
all focusing on the numbers and how fast
they rise because that's president it
and I think what we should look at is
basically beyond the curve so we will
spike at a certain level and I think the
big question is what is the capability
of the normal economy to absorb those
people again because if you look at the
u.s. now we have all these stimulus
packages that will make sure that yeah
the people are taken care of that cannot
last forever and I think yeah that's the
biggest concern in the future not the
rise of the numbers right now but the
decrease of the numbers are after we hit
the all-time high that will happen for
sure all right I said no doubt the next
few months are going to be very very
difficult indeed what about getting back
to where we were how long is it going to
take yeah so the economy will restart
again and the speed of risk of this
restart will depend on how long this
yeah this outbreak lost basically and I
first see that in certain industries
that can take a long time I'm in close
contact with some entrepreneurs in China
that are now reopen again but you see
that the levels of business after
reopening are not even close to a half
of what yeah what it was at the
beginning of this year so I think when
you look at hospitality tourism the
restart will be really slow but
hopefully some of the other you know
parts of the economy will pick up faster
a great here your perspective to
appreciate that that's a baron raff who
is the CEO of hava
thanks very much